los líderes europeos se reúnen en
Bruselas en una cumbre en que de nuevo
uno de los puntos principales es la
ayuda ucraneal ayuda militar y
financiera se quiere mantener pero aún
así desde Bruselas está hablando de
incluso redoblarla tras los últimos
acontecimientos del pasado fin de semana
en Rusia en que ha dejado claramente
debilitado al kremlin y que puede tener
un impacto en la contienda los líderes
europeos como viene siendo habitual
hablarán por videoconferencia con el
presidente de Ucrania Vladimir zelenskin
que también por primera vez se va a
debatir cómo ofrecer garantías de
seguridad al país además también se
hablará de la reconstrucción de cómo
utilizar los bienes congelados del Banco
Central de Rusia que se encuentran en
Europa aproximadamente unos 3.000
millones de euros Y cómo pueden
contribuir a la reconstrucción del país
además los líderes europeos también se
reúnen con el secretario general de la
otan James toltenberg a dos semanas de
una Cumbre clave en lituania la reunión
de hoy sin tampoco evita los temas más
espinosos sobre todo la migración
Hungría y Polonia quieren Mostrar su
descontento por el acuerdo llegado a
principios de este mes de un reporto
equitativo de los migrantes y
solicitantes de asilo que llegan a
Europa pero también se va a hablar de
Cómo reforzar Los acuerdos con países de
origen y de tránsito sobre todo con
túnez para evitar más llegadas de
personas que solicitan asilo y que
muchas veces se juegan la vida